[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver dans
le 7-8 loisirs tout aussi été sorti dans
le département on commence tout de suite
avec le sommaire de ce numéro nous
parlerons de la serre aux papillons
situé à là que les italiens les yvelines
l'établissement propose des stages de
peinture et de compositions florales
nous recevrons olivier py tel le
directeur adjoint pour nous donner plus
de détails
à guyancourt les adolescents de la ferme
de bel ébat rejoue le classique de
george orwell des cochons se prennent le
pouvoir pour instaurer leur régime
c'est la ferme des animaux et celle à
découvrir sur scène c'est une première
une boutique consacrée à la saga harry
potter a ouvert ses portes à versailles
michael et demi d'euros à trouver le
chemin de traverse pour s'y rendre
notre rendez-vous juniors nous aurons
droit à une petite visite et jusqu'à fin
septembre 3 touahri joue les jurassic
park 16 animatroniques de dinosaures
sont installés dans un espace dédié à
côté du parcours les jeunes
paléontologues peuvent s'exercer sur le
camp de fouilles est une nouveauté cette
année une expérience de réalité
virtuelle les visiteurs sont téléportés
125 millions d'années en arrière parmi
les dinosaures
et comme dirait un certain john hammond
le parc a dépensé sans compter on écoute
le responsable de thoiry
alors c'est des dinosaures en fait qui
ont été créés aux états unis
c'est une société américaine qui est
spécialisé là dedans c'est vraiment des
gens très très très spécialisés et ils
sont montrés donc pour la deuxième fois
en france
et puis après on nous avons fait toute
la scénographie avec nos équipes
techniques avec nos équipes de
jardiniers de paysagistes et puis la
partie réalité virtuelle
nous avons travaillé donc avec cette
société anime à tours et avec les
studios qui sont à marseille
[Musique]
et un peu d'exotisme dans ce set chèques
loisirs nous partons à la rencontre des
papillons du monde entier à seulement
quelques kilomètres de chez nous à la
queue-lez-yvelines la serre aux
papillons plonge les visiteurs dans une
jungle équatoriale parmi les papillons
multicolores et jusqu'à juillet des
stages sont également proposés avec nous
olivier py tel le directeur adjoint
bonjour olivier bonjour alors je
l'évoqué rapidement en introduction est
ce que nous pourrions nous dire un petit
peu plus sur votre établissement
combien avez vous de papillons et d'où
vient-il oui alors donc c'est une c'est
une grande serre dans laquelle se
trouvent les papillons avec dans des
plantes exotiques
donc c'est une c'est une serre dans
laquelle il fait 28 degrés avec
énormément d'humilité dans laquelle vous
retrouve effectivement tout un tas de
sorte de papillon
on reçoit à peu près l'équivalent de 700
chrysalide toutes les semaines
donc de façon à ce que après ça puisse
s'envoler à l'intérieur de notre taux
sert donc cette serre c'est l'une des
plus grandes serres de france
puisqu'elle fait un peu plus de haut
niveau surface un peu plus de 1000 m² et
vous ne faites pas que les papillons
vous propose également des stages depuis
plusieurs semaines et y en a justement
samedi 15 avril sur la composition
florale alors en quoi ça consiste
oui tout à fait donc il ya une fleuriste
donc très chevronnés qui vient former
nos clients donné une petite formation
et là ce thème si donc ça va être
effectivement pour pâques
forcément il manque composé donc ils
vont créer des soies des compositions
florales des bouquets alors le 22 avril
vous en avez un autre alors là c'est de
la peinture cette fois avec un artiste
oui tout à fait donc initiation à la
peinture acrylique
donc nous avons une artiste monique
borreil donc qui va venir justement
donner des cours de peinture
cette personne expose également à la
jardinerie
donc le fait à la fois des coups rudes
et expositions si on veut voir ses
tableaux c'est à la jardinerie ou à la
mère poulard tout à fait entre autres
alors pourquoi proposer ces stages au
public ses nouveaux alors ces nouveaux
effectivement donc on avait déjà la
formation floral depuis quelques années
mais le
le fait d'en proposer d'autres
effectivement pour nos clients je pense
que c'est intéressant parce que ça ça
crée notamment un lien avec nos clients
et qui est différent du commerce
donc là on est sûr de la formation de
l'explication nous avons tout un tas de
deux petits ateliers comme ça qui se
décline alors on parlait de la formation
floral il ya la peinture il ya moi ce
que j'ai baptisé les leçons de choses et
là c'est un atelier spécial pour
vraiment un atelier jardin qui est notre
coeur de métier
donc là c'est une personne
françoise donc paumé qui est notre coach
gerba qui vient donner des cours sur des
gestes simples pour le jardin pour
attendre un petit peu plus pour pouvoir
faire son propre
voilà tout à fait partagé fric etc ou
fleurs avec des gestes simples en fait
on a des fois oublié mais après on a
aussi madame france aubert qui vient
nous faire du patchwork donc là elle va
apprendre à nos clients et à notre sens
plus le patchwork
oui oui puis c'est une dame qui expose
ôter aux états unis et apparemment ça
fait fureur là bas donc elle est cette
dame et sur l'accueil zibeline donc là
encore on travaille avec une de nos
clientes en fait qui vient qui va
expliquer et faire surtout faire faire
faire réaliser donc des petites des
petites choses en patchwork des petits
jeux des petits objets et pour en
revenir juste un tout petit peu plus sur
la serre aux papillons parce que vous
n'arriviez tout à l'heure de chrysalide
alors vous mettez en place un parcours
pour comprendre la vie d'un papillon
alors qu'est ce que c'est justement
alors tout à fait donc on a un grand un
grand pas d'eau qui explique alors avec
des questions simples 1 pour les enfants
c'est vraiment orienté pour les enfants
donc vous avez des questions il ya une
quinzaine de questions et puis à chaque
fois vous avez trois réponses donc il ya
forcément de réponses qui sont fausses
et donc c'est un petit parcours comme ça
apprendre à découvrir le papillon et les
différents stades aussi de développement
1 que ça soit donc de l'oeuf jusqu'au
jusqu'au pape y ait l'idée justement
dans tel endroit c'est aussi de divertir
mais également de sensibiliser le public
à l'environnement à la protection de
l'environnement
oui tout à fait tout à fait parce que la
serre aux papillons en fête
ces petits insectes sont assez fragiles
notamment avec les pesticides
c'est un petit peu embêtant avec
l'utilisation des pesticides
donc nous au niveau de la serre aux
papillons faut savoir que à l'intérieur
donc on a des plantes exotiques
elles sont comme dans le jardin des fois
malade atteinte d'insectes etc
et nous on utilise donc la lutte
intégrée la lutte biologique donc on
fait venir d'autres insectes donc qui
sont prédateurs
pour pour tuer ces c d'autres insectes
donc on fait cette cette protection donc
écologique
cette sensibilisation a fait pas très
bien en tout cas merci beaucoup les
capitales d'être venu sur le plateau de
jeu 7 8 loisirs donc on le rappelle des
stages de samedi 15 et 22 avril et bien
d'autres également retrouver sur le site
internet de la serre aux papillons et
elle est ouverte d'autres manières tous
les jours pour venir découvrir ses
protégés merci beaucoup olivier merci
merci à vous et à guyancourt les
spectateurs sont invités à la ferme des
animaux lors d'une révolte les animaux
chasse les fermiers pour instaurer leur
république le classique de george orwell
revisité par la jeune troupe de la ferme
de bel ébat et la compagnie in code
n'allez pas imaginer que gouverner d'une
partie de plaisir
des animaux qui prennent le pouvoir dans
une ferme dans un souci d'égalité mais
tout ne va pas se passer comme prévu
les cochons vont instaurer leur régime
totalitaire qui est racontée là c'est
dans le pouvoir politique mais c'est
dans les cours de récréation aussi je
veux dire c'est que c'est quelque chose
qui se passe dans chaque entreprise dans
chaque là où il ya un noyau d'humanité
de travail de tension de ceux qui
veulent effectivement imposer leurs
choix ceux qui se font imposer les choix
une critique des rapports humains
société mais aussi une satire de la
révolution russe la ferme des animaux de
george orwell un classique de la
littérature qui retrace l'arrivée de
staline au pouvoir un sujet complexe
abordés par ces adolescents de la ferme
de bel ébat et à des certaines personnes
qui sont manipulatrice un peu et qui
donc reprennent les idées des autres en
faisant croire que ce sont les leurs moi
je joue un manipulateur un cochon c'est
sage et qui va faire des grands discours
qui va un peu les jeux hyper carry en
fait je suis méchante samyn distance et
du coup ils sont plus à l'aise s'oublie
complètement que ce canton fait la
chèvre donc là nous le mouton on
s'oublie
après plusieurs semaines de préparation
le public est invité à découvrir la
pièce les 21 et 22 avril
[Musique]
cette semaine pour notre rendez-vous
juniors on va parler d'un sorcier bien
connu en prend la direction de
versailles +2 9 ans après le dernier
volet d'harry potter une boutique
consacrée presque entièrement à la saga
du jeune sorcier s'est ouverte dans la
commune
une première en france nos deux
magiciens michael et demi d'euros et
nicolas landry ils sont allés pour nous
la saga harry potter s'invite à
versailles boutique spécialisée s'est
ouverte début février à côté du vieux
marché de la ville
je vais ouvrir les portes de cette
mystérieuse mutzig et j'espère que la
magie va opérer
je suis avec frédéric le gérant de cette
boutique alors frédéric pourquoi avoir
créé cet univers harry potter ici à
versailles alors tout d'abord c'est que
moi je suis déjà fan d'harry potter et
des animaux fantastiques et de l'auteure
jk rowling c'est compliqué pour les fans
de trouver en fait des objets au même
endroit donc pourquoi ne pas avoir créé
ma propre boutique et trouvez moi aussi
du coup mes objets et propose aux fans
en fait de trouver les objets d'harry
potter au même endroit et pas faire dix
mille magasins ou commander dix fois sur
internet
m
e
[Musique]
frédéric je vois que vous avez quelques
petites baguettes juste derrière vous
alors voilà est-ce que vous me
conseillez une baguette en particulier
alors à la base c'est la baguette qui
choisissons sortiez ben on va peut-être
tenté le coup avec une baguette de queen
i got shane jennings est fantastique
c'est un peu mou foldingue ou qu'une
petite femme un peu apprêtée chose comme
ça donc tu peux faire le geste ait pu
voir si quelque chose se soulève c'est
le sorcier wingardium leviosa wingardium
leviosa wingardium leviosa pas les vieux
ça bon je vais tenter ça ou de garde
youm leviosa eh bah non il n'y a rien
qui s'est soulevée donc effectivement
c'est pas forcément une baguette qui
fait pour toi je suis juste un moldu pas
forcément on va voir si le choixpeau
peut-être décerner une maison d'un gris
et une cravate de chez poufsouffle on va
regarder avec le chapeau qui est juste
derrière moi alors le choixpeau il
choisit en fait la maison où tu vas
aller donc on va bien voir on va essayer
[Musique]
angers7 voilà qu'est ce qu'ils proposent
est là il dit pas grand chose donc
peut-être qu'effectivement tu resteras
un maul des oubliettes
[Musique]
merci de m'avoir fait réapparaître c'est
normal c'est normal oui non
alors quelles sont les grandes dates à
retenir pour votre magasin alors on fait
venir un acteur le 27 mai prochain
mais pour l'instant on va juste un
indice c'est que c'est un requin c'est
tout c'est tout pas n'ont pour l'instant
pas de nom
on attend ça avec impatience en tout cas
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
est à noter nous avons le nom pour le 27
mai la boutique harry potter accueillera
crise renkin plus connue pour jouer le
personnage de percy weasley dans la saga
les fans pourront échanger avec lui et
prendre des photos jusqu'au 31 mai il
encourt organise son concours photo
regarde habitants quatre catégories
regard sur l'enfance le travail la
nature et le patrimoine
les favoris pour en gagner un shooting
photo en famille avec un professionnel
et des entrées au cinéma
plus de détails sur le site internet de
la ville c'est la fin de ce set 8
loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]